The easiest way to explain how animations work inside a sequencer is we'll just add
an animation track inside using the mannequin that we were referencing before.
If you don't know where that is, you can follow this hierarchy down here.
You can also filter out skeletal meshes.
So if you click this button and click skeletal mesh, it'll give you all the skeletal meshes
that are available inside the content folder, which are this series of skeletal meshes here.
So let's first of all create a level sequence.
So you can do this a couple of different ways.
In my content folder, I'm going to right click, New Folder, and just call this SEQ for Sequencer.
I'm going to untick, make sure if you tick the skeletal mesh filter, make sure you untick
that, otherwise you won't be able to see any sequencer files.
I'm going to right click, Animation, and then go to Level Sequence.
So right click in this grey box, Animation and Level Sequence.
I'm just going to call this SEQ underscore Manny Walk.
Manny is the name of the skeletal mesh that we have.
You can also create sequences through this button at the top for quick access.
I just like to create them through the content browser so I know exactly where they're being
saved and stored.
And then I'm just going to double click the sequencer.
So the first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to pin it to my tab up here.
Don't worry if you don't have this Merge Axis window, I'm going to close that.
It's up to you what windows you have open and the kind of organisation of your workspace
here.
And so we've got a sequencer.
We've not got any information in the sequencer.
So the first thing I want to do now is back into my content browser.
I want to make sure the content is selected, skeletal mesh and I will find my mannequin
character.
I will drag my mannequin into position here.
I will use spacebar to toggle through the different widgets to manipulate the mannequin
into place.
So just by tapping spacebar we go through location, rotation and scale.
I've got the mannequin roughly into position here.
I'll go back into my sequencer window and I will, with my mannequin selected, I will
right click, Active to Sequence, Add SK Mannequin.
So if I deselect mannequin, deselects the mannequin in the editor.
If I select mannequin, it selects the mannequin in the editor.
So we've got a one to one relationship with the mannequin.
So just make sure you have that.
If not, make sure you add that track again by selecting the mannequin, right click, Active
to Sequence and add the mannequin there.
So the first thing we'll do is we'll add a transform here.
So we'll add a new key under the transform.
So just select this little circle option here on 000.
I'm going to drag along this dark bar along the top.
I'm going to drag right to the end and I'll put my timeline around 148 units.
I'll use my mouse to navigate the scene.
So again, right mouse button pans around, left mouse button to back and forwards, both
mouse buttons to move around.
So somewhere around this end point, I'm going to move the mannequin into position.
I'll drag them up here and I will add another key here.
Now if I press this button to front here and I press play, the mannequin will move over
the duration over that amount of units.
So make sure that you don't need to delete this key but I'm just going to click the
key and press delete on my keyboard.
Make sure you don't have this first key selected, then move the mannequin and then try and set
the key later down the timeline because the mannequin will snap back to the original position.
So you need to make sure you go to the time that you want, move then the actor that you
want to bind the key to and then add the key.
And then if I press rewind here to front and then press play, we got that movement.
Now you can just add whatever kind of additional movement you want.
Maybe I'm going to, around this point, I'm going to drag the mannequin up a little bit
in a perfect, very precise manner.
Not really.
I will maybe go here, maybe at this key here.
Oh classic example of me not moving the mannequin correctly.
There we go, add key and then maybe, maybe I'll rotate this just to see that and there
we go.
A very imprecise, precise movement of mannequin going up the little ramp here.
So we've got some basic movement but the mannequin's not got any animation.
So let's go ahead and add some animation now.
So I'm just going to, again, to front button here.
I'm going to go to the animation tab and you might see a series of animations here, especially
if you've got multiple animations for the mannequin.
You might see walks and idols and different things like that.
I just have a jog available to me in this project.
So I'm just going to select the jog animation and you'll see that first of all the mannequin
has a little jog animation.
So we'll do that and what I can also do is because it runs out of space around frame
60, I can actually just drag this animation along here and it will continue to loop straight
through the duration of this.
Now because the mannequin is running, it's feeling a bit slow so you may just want to
end up bringing all these keys in anyway.
You may just want to do something like this and this and this and this and you may just
think that it looks way better like this just because it gives it more speed.
But completely up to you how you do your animations.
The other thing to note here is if you want to do a walk into an idol for example, I could
add another animation here.
So like on frame 60, I could go to animation and jog forward and I have these two jogs.
I can actually just drag and drop this forward run over the previous one and you'll see some
blending behavior going on here.
So especially if I had a walk animation into an idol animation, I could blend from the
walk into the idol over a series of frames, you know, however long you want that duration,
that crossfade to be and that would actually blend the animations quite nicely.
So there's quite a lot of tools just for a few button presses inside a sequence that
you can get access to.
We've just discussed the transform and animation track and just with those two alone, you can
create some quite complex animation sequences and you can even then like we said, render
them out to the take recorder if you so wished.
So what did we cover there?
So we added a track for a skeletal mesh.
We added some keyframes in the timeline and we chose the time that we wanted to make these
changes.
And in this example here, we've got an idol into a walk and then back into an idol just
with a few keyframes down.
And so it's completely up to you then the approach that you take when creating these
sequences.
So when you finish with your sequence, you can create a linked animation sequence if
you want.
You can bake out the animation as we said before, you can just bake this to its own
animation sequence now.
You can export your animations in the FBX if you want to use those somewhere outside
of Unreal.
And you can also edit with the FK control rig just to get some more fine tuning going
on if you wanted to.